i think it's good to solicit feedback
and particularly negative feedback
why are you where you are in your life
the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself
it's a great experience to be an
entrepreneur
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
lessons from elon musk oprah winfrey and
other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one look for feedback with elon
musk
i don't have a mentor per se although i
try to i try to get feedback from as
many people as possible
um and um so i have like friends and i
ask them
to you know what they think of the stuff
that and the other thing and
um you know as much you know
larry's a good relay page is a good
friend of mine value his advice a lot
um and many other good friends and
uh so so i think it's good to solicit
feedback
and particularly negative feedback
actually because you know obviously
people aren't don't love the idea of
giving you negative feedback um unless
unless
it's like some you know on on blogs
they do that rule number two believe
many of you as i have been as i
am are where you are in your life
based upon what you believe and it's not
just what you think
you believe on the surface it's also
your shadow beliefs
that are holding you back from moving
into
the life that you believe you deserve
what i know is if you're not looking at
the shadows if you're not looking at
what is
subconsciously running through the tape
in your mind
telling yourself you're not good enough
you're not worthy enough you're not
smart enough you're not enough which is
a tape that's playing for a lot of
people if you're not conscious of that
then you end up acting out of that
belief system
and not out of what you know to be the
truest
or want to be the truest for yourself
but you don't become what you want
because so much of wanting is about
living in the space of what you
don't have that's why jim carrey's story
is so powerful because he started to act
as though he already had it
he would go up to mulholland drive he
would drive away saying
thinking i already have those things i
just haven't accessed them as yet
i believe those things are going to come
to me and i'm going to act like they are
so i'm going to move forward in my life
in order to
draw that to myself in such a way that
my
actions are in alignment with what i say
i believe so if you start to think about
that really
why are you where you are in your life
the choices that you have made
have been because of what you believe to
be true for yourself
lesson number three learn from mistakes
with jack ma
it's a great experience to be an
entrepreneur
life is so cool when you become
entrepreneur
in my life the day
i never write a book for myself i think
those people write books are getting too
old
my life's just the beginning the day
when i want to write i want to write a
book alibaba 1001 mistakes and i want to
tell my kids
how many tough days i have gone through
how many miss silly mistakes i've made
and this is the best experience this is
because it's easy to be good but it's
tough to be bad
in the first five years steve in my
company
i always giving the case studies
of failure companies to every of my
people today the thing i want to share
more with the young entrepreneurs is
how many mistakes we made how many
companies bankrupted
why they bankrupted i never teach like
mba teach
people how they succeed how that one
success
when you when young people learn that
too much they think
they can easily succeed going to
business is like going to battlefield
the only those people survive win and
you
know how to avoid stupid action so when
you learn the mistakes
that's the failures cases not to avoid
mistakes but when you know when you meet
these mistakes
you know how to face it how to solve it
how to challenge it lesson number four
lean into your fears with grant cardone
what do you think it'll take for you to
get over insecurity moving forward
i'm not trying to you're not trying i'm
not trying to i thought you said if you
could get rid of it you'd be able to do
bigger
the unbelievable but but it's not it's
not it's not a target i have
letting go of insecurity no i think it's
just a human condition i think it's part
of the game i think it's part of
being a human being any more than i want
to get rid of my arms
you know or my legs or my arms and my
legs my body
my body is a limitation yeah you know so
um how do you manage it better than like
for people that are saying
i you know i want a 10x but i always
have insecurity and fear that i'm going
to fail and people are going to show up
and
yeah the deal's going to i'm going to go
broke how do you personally
get a conversation to yourself to the
insecurity and fear
yeah it's not stop it's come
you know for me for me fear fear the
things i i'm scared of i'm like
come on you know that it's calling me
says hey come play over here
it's an indicator it's a good indicator
not a bad indicator lean into it
lean into it come play with me okay so i
either have fear because it's really
dangerous
and stupid or like physically dangerous
yeah like let me get to the edge of this
thing i'm gonna get on the other side of
that thing i'm probably gonna be scared
yeah now why am i gonna be scared though
like
because i don't know what it feels like
to fall you know this many floors and
hit
yeah maybe it does maybe there's no big
deal about maybe dying is not even a big
deal right
but i don't have the exp i don't
consciously have the experience
so you know i used to be like
i can't buy a 78 000 house i was
terrified the first house i bought
i don't know what i'm doing because you
have experience i don't have the
experience man
this this is the problem and you're not
going to have the experience if you
don't move through the fear
and a lot of people do it once and then
they don't do it again you got
like it's not going away yeah it's just
gonna
you're gonna get used to you're gonna
get used to the ski boots
you know the first time you put them on
man they're freaking banging your shins
like i can't mend but you just we're
into them
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here lesson
number five focus
on customer experience with jeff bezos
so anyway we we got this company just
about ready to launch
and uh we're looking at it and looking
at this little tiny fulfillment center
we were
here by then in this building we had a
basement fulfillment center
to call it a fulfillment center was very
grand there's a lot of puffery
it was 400 square feet which is about
the size of a one car garage
and we launched this business and
we're looking at it and we didn't know
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't
and in fact one of the software
engineers looked at this little space
and he said i can't figure out whether
this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
and indeed we didn't know we had no idea
whether anybody would want to buy things
in this way the business plan
called for generating sales very slowly
as customers changed their
attitudes the original business plan
which i thought was very optimistic at
the time
called for amazon.com to generate 70
million dollars in sales in the year
2001.
we actually generated an excess of 3
billion dollars in sales in the year
2001
and we knew by the way that we were
really on to something in those first 30
days
in the first 30 days we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries
with not a dollar of advertising just
all word of mouth the first year we
didn't spend anything on advertising
all of it was word of mouth and that
really forged the company as a
that we were going to focus on customer
experience because we saw the power of
word of mouth so
so very very clearly in those early days
there's something great about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being
it's wonderful so people actually tell
you what they really think
usually in all caps
and uh so we get lots of uh info and
feedback from our customers and we try
to try to use it well
lesson number six love what you do with
warren buffett
how would you advise people who aren't
necessarily going into a career field in
which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe performing
arts or
music how would you advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well it is true that a market system
uh does not pay as well in some
in some activities as as
might seem appropriate for the
importance of those activities the
society
just take teaching for example i mean
teaching does not pay well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're the teachers
of your children are is who your
accountant is or you know
uh whatever or who's winning the
heavyweight title of the world or that
sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice uh whether
you're going to go into something
that for many people it'd be it'd be a
fundamental choice whether you're going
to go into something you love or
something to
to try and make a lot of money i think
that generally it pays to go with what
you love
and i think that
it's very hard to find people when they
get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i
i don't think anybody's ever ever said
that to me that they wish they'd gone
into something else
where they were uncomfortable doing it
or didn't enjoy it
didn't feel very productive but made a
lot of money so i don't i don't think
you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work i would go to work
in whatever turns you on it may turn out
that it'll it'll be more profitable than
than you can think but almost everybody
here will make
enough money unless they get some
terrible habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is is uh is pretty darn good i
mean
it is it's not necessary to have
huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was
at my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it
when i had about that i bought it 41
years ago i like the house then i like
the house now
i mean if you think about it if you have
a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating mcdonald's so we're we're to
push
on on on food i mean you know in fact i
hope it's dairy queen actually and maybe
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order and
we both can afford it uh you know you'll
you'll wear the same clothes i wear i'll
pay more for my suits but as soon as i
put them on they look cheap on me so
we'll look about the same and uh uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and then and
what difference does it make if you have
50 more rooms or you know guest houses
or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the
about the greenskeeper or something when
you get through so i
i i have been in the houses of people uh
where the houses are worth um
oh probably 200 times uh what my house
is worth and
i would not be any happier in those
houses at all in fact i'd be less happy
i just have one more thing to
to worry about and you know the dozens
of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah
uh we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive a car's about eight
years old i don't know what it's worth
now but
it gets me around fine i mean i'm
perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll we'll work on the same computer
pretty much
the only difference will be how we
travel long distances
you know i will fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than than flying
southwest airlines or something and
which uh
i've got nothing against but that's the
one real big difference and
other than that i do what i like every
day i hope you you'll do what you like
every day to do and
i work with nice people i hope you work
with nice people
and there's 24 hours in the day and
those are where the hours go so
great wealth uh
is the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and and to trade
a decent income and something you love
doing and something where you feel
worthwhile doing it
for huge wealth where you
trade off a lot of your principles uh
would be a terrible mistake
and lesson number seven the last one
before very special bonus clip
is think about the future with bill
gates
when you have a tragedy like this
pandemic there is
always the possibility you're going to
narrow
your community that you care about
you're going to think about yourself or
your family
not the whole country including those
who've been
been somewhat left behind likewise
there's a risk
looking at africa and other developing
countries and say no we need to help
them out because
difficulties there of not enough food
are really extreme and
small amounts of the budget less than
one percent can help them out
likewise you don't want to just think
about the here and now you also want to
think about the future after all
the government failed us by not
anticipating this pandemic
there were voices like mine and ted talk
and other venues that
kind of said hey get ready we don't know
when but it's coming
sadly that didn't happen another thing
we
trust government to get us ready for is
climate change
that's coming and it won't be as easy as
creating a vaccine to solve it
and so right now terms of people's
sympathy
being broad you know being willing to
address other problems even though
they're not
here right now i am actually seeing a
lot of positive voices people saying
make sure the recovery is a green
recovery europe
has done a lot on that and so and
actually the dialogue
in politics about you know does climate
change matter
is stronger today than it's ever been so
this closing in
and only worrying about the short term
i'm not seeing that
of course your audience which is very
young will be the key
to saying let's not just
look at this short term let's start the
investments
that deal with inequities let's start
the investments that can make sure
climate change doesn't come in and and
have even more tragic results than this
pandemic does
young people thinking about policies
getting
involved i think i'm seeing an uptick i
hope that's sustained
because they're you know they're the
ones who will really do the innovative
work
now i've got a very special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you get
motivated inspired you have a 35 chance
of following through but when you get
motivated inspired and you create a plan
of action
you have a over 90 chance of following
through and when you share with other
people
it jumps to 95 chance your likelihood
of following through and so i want that
to be you from this video we don't just
watch videos here believe nation
we do something we take action so i want
to know your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate you during
my california springs and summers
i spent most of my days in the high
sierras in yosemite valley
working as a river guide and a rock
climbing instructor
i loved those jobs but unfortunately
they didn't pay that well
so i also got a job working a couple of
days a week as a computer programmer
back in berkeley i had learned a program
in college
i didn't love programming but it was fun
and i was good at it and computer pro
programming gave me the same kind of
satisfaction
as solving math problems and playing
chess
both things i enjoyed before before i
became a confused teenager
at this point in my life i thought i was
making real progress on my journey of
self-discovery
i had found a cause i had a couple of
jobs that i love
and one that was fun and paid the bills
i was pretty happy with my life
my wife was not
what she saw was a college dropout who
spent too much time in the mountains
doing
foolish things she wanted me to work
full time as a computer programmer
or go back to college and finish my
degree
we compromised sort of
i started taking classes at uc berkeley
i took several classes but the only one
i can remember
was a sailing class taught at berkeley
marina
once again i fell in love and began a
lifelong affair
with the limitless omnipotent pacific
ocean
when my class was over i wanted to buy a
sailboat
my wife said this was the single
stupidest
idea she had ever heard in her entire
life
she accused me of being irresponsible
and she told me i lacked ambition
she kicked me out and then she divorced
me
[Music]
this was a pivotal moment in my life
my family was still mad at me for not
going to medical school
and now my wife was divorcing me because
i lacked ambition
it looked like a reoccurrence of the
same old problem
once again i was unable to live up to
the expectations of others
but this time i was not disappointed in
myself
for failing to be the person they
thought i
should be their dreams
and my dreams were different
i would never confuse the two of them
again
[Music]
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there i find if i don't get enough sleep
then i'm i'm quite grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way
and and also like i try to sort of
figure out what's the
right amount of sleep